el 30 de diciembre hillmán hizo un
triste descubrimiento caminando por el
bosque luego de que un excursionista lo
alertará era el cuerpo de un lince
el animal que ha estado monitoreando
durante más de 30 años estaba allí entre
las ramas muertas entre la primera vez
que lo vimos y el día siguiente cuando
volví a la agencia de biodiversidad ya
se lo habían comido los zorros
parcialmente así que si no lo hubiéramos
encontrado por casualidad habría
desaparecido escrito el film o el cuerpo
del lince como prueba con el agujero
abierto en su estómago claramente
visible después de una autopsia las
autoridades concluyeron que había muerto
por heridas de bala una muerte que está
además para este defensor de la fauna
era completamente evitable porque fue un
acto deliberado de una persona que
quiere borrar el lince del mapa o al
menos de esta zona y eso es inaceptable
se abrió una investigación judicial pero
hoy el mohán tiene pocas esperanzas en
ella pues dice que rara vez tienen éxito
en su lugar decidió hacer un llamamiento
a los ciudadanos ofreciendo mil euros
por cualquier información que pueda
ayudar a encontrar al cazador furtivo'
denunció denunciar un delito no es una
vergüenza es un acto cívico que
contribuye a que se respeten las normas
de nuestro país es por el interés de
todos pero no todos en la región están
de acuerdo con la idea de una recompensa
que subió a cinco mil euros gracias a
donaciones privadas
los cazadores locales por su parte se
muestran contrariados asesinos hay algo
desagradable en este incentivo
financiero la caza furtiva siempre se ha
asociado a la casa nos guste o no
es un cazador que no respeta las reglas
pero ni siquiera las recompensas parecen
poder romper el silencio que reina aquí
y en aries en el sur de francia este
valle puede parecer tranquilo pero está
en el centro del revuelo desde el
descubrimiento de un oso muerto con
heridas de bala es un acto ilegal pero
que no los escandaliza a todos en las
montañas por arriba del bosque allá hay
un pedazo cubierto de nieve allá arriba
y eso no lo afecte en absoluto no puede
matar a 20 o 30 de ellos no me importa
de hecho me alegraría de qué se trata
eso de proteger a los animales que matan
a otro es una ong llamada si ser parte
ofrece 50 mil euros por información pero
hasta ahora nadie se ha presentado un
hecho que agradece este granjero cuyas
ovejas han sido atacadas por osos
durante los últimos cuatro años
eso muestra que hay personas
comprometidas con su territorio con el
pastoralismo con todo lo que vive en
estas montañas y a pesar de la enorme
suma no han dicho nada
y eso demuestra la solidaridad de la
montaña creo que es imprescindible en
este tema los países que están fallos
pero el sistema de recompensas ha
funcionado en otras partes del país como
en la costa de bretaña donde se
encontraron dos focas decapitadas en
2019 chiche park había ofrecido diez mil
euros por información lo que llevó a la
identificación de dos pescadores que se
enfrentaron a la justicia el año pasado
afirmaron que no estaban pescando
ilegalmente pues las cocas estaban
muertas todas las focas estaban muertas
todas las devolvemos al mar mi jefe
debería haber hecho una declaración y
debería haberme dicho no david esos
están protegidas no se nos permite
llevarnos a estos animales muertos los
pescadores fueron multados con 1.500
euros matar ilegalmente a un animal en
peligro de extinción se castiga con 150
mil euros de multa y tres años de cárcel
pero hasta ahora estas sentencias han
resultado ser hipotéticas aunque los
humanos no están en la cima de la cadena
alimentaria siguen actuando como si así
lo fuese